then Oasis came along we didn't have the
Internet
you know if we divide the internet we're
doing bigger than the universe I don't
live to work I work to live you know
what's the point being a rock star if
you can't just bum around through yeah
the gigs and the tours and I like you
should be are in fun on doing those
things Oh what the you know we do the
pool huh he's an English musician
singer-songwriter and guitarist he was
the vocalist songwriter and lead
guitarist for the rock band Oasis many
have praised his songwriting with George
Martin calling him the finest songwriter
of his generation he's no logger and
here's my take on his top ten rules of
success and as always guys as you're
watching the videos you can hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well also as you are
writing something down it's much more
likely to stick in your head to enjoy
that they can't be the greatest band in
the world playing in a pub somewhere
tonight the nobody's heard of with the
internet if you're great you're going to
make it yeah you know that's just a fact
you know there's not there can't be any
well we don't make it because you know
working class or something do not I mean
it's like if you're writing the best
songs in the world you're going to make
it the end you know when when when Oasis
came along we didn't have the internet
you know if we divide the internet we're
doing bigger than the universe I mean we
could have reached everybody yeah you
know but we did it we were forced to do
it the hard way you know these new bands
have all the advantage of you know these
devices that can get you to everybody in
the world at the click of a button and
you know all you've got to come up with
is alright you had the difficult bit is
the songs if you're a songwriter or a
composer you're kind of in it for life I
enjoy the writing although it can be
very frustrating when it's not happening
but I do enjoy that I genuinely don't
know what I would do some people in some
quarters give you stick so being like a
formulaic songwriter but I'd say and
chasing yesterday's kind of progressive
really isn't it so I am select well
relatively speaking does that mean
anyway what did it mean and who are who
are some people the Guardian because of
garden well everybody's got an opinion
anyways you know I mean but I don't know
I don't I don't think about it too much
it's sorry if it sounds good to me
I put it out there not begging people to
come see me I'll buy it or anything like
that if my audience such a thing exists
gets it that's great and if they don't
that's great to know I mean I kind of
like it creatively where were you at at
the end of a laces um creatively why I
would always take a lot of time off
after big world tours anyway to not I
mean you've got a if I was a cadets
project that we used to undertake would
be two years with the tour are from the
minute you own a studio at the end of
the last year would be two years
so you've got a if I was working for two
years
I'd have to balance it out with time off
because I don't I don't live to work I
work to live you know what's the point
being a rock star if you can't just bum
around through yeah well it's not quite
working every day you consider it work I
mean if someone some people would look
at your life and think that that work
isn't is something you your passion so
it's what our it's what you live for
well on the one hand it's my hobby
tonight I mean I don't have any other
hobbies by watching football but you
know I'd like to say I thought I
couldn't go from spending two years on a
project and then six weeks later saying
right when I'm going to start something
else now there's got a bead I this is
just me first me because some people
like to work all the time I have to I
have to go away and I don't pick up the
guitar and I add something happens and
then I have to feel that I really really
miss it like I might go and see a shell
from another band and think I really
want to get back on stage and then I'll
think about doing something we all were
all in the music game for different
reasons Joe I mean and I am NOT a
workaholic
I'm just not I pay for and release my
own records and I produced it I don't
have anybody saying to me boys
think it's a bit long you know or an A&R
guy saying why does the guitar solo
coming after the first chorus and then
there's a big guy you know John I mean
yeah I'm allow myself now to follow my
instincts and sometimes they're wrong
sometimes there's like you know well I
believe in what I do in it in the same
reason I believe in and I'm comfortable
with who I am why where I look and how I
are now I'm perceived I take the writing
and the recording of my music very
seriously and the rest of it I don't
take seriously at all I don't take
myself seriously I don't take things
like these interview seriously I would
never do an interview where I might well
you know tell you how I wrote that song
or what it means nobody gives it yeah I
don't care you know so yeah I don't I
don't take a great deal of it seriously
if I'm being honest apart from the
cords they're serious because they last
forever the gigs and the tours and I
like you should be are in fun on doing
those things or what the you know we do
them for I don't know anything about
gigs is there's so many factors that
make a great gig like I mean I've kind
of stayed so many times thinking that's
awful for whatever reason you know your
salman will come in it was out fun to
say that's the best thing I've ever seen
you go really oh then you'll be offstage
and think but your band has played great
and you really button they sign up to
win and say well I lost the bass for six
songs you know I really are the
lightning man I'll say yes on the lights
didn't work so you're not I mean it's
kind of I don't really have don't any
judge gigs while I'm doing it I'm just
in the moment I'm singing the songs when
I come onstage I don't like talking
about it so when you're writing a song I
mean how do you put it to a muster
process I just play the guitar and I
might be playing a set of chords for
three months and I will just be
fascinated by the chords and nothing
will happen and then one day if I
persevere with it enough and melody will
arrive and then the lyrics will evolve
and then to get a band to play it I come
from the school of music or we all did
in Oasis where you just say like it goes
like this
you know I don't know I know the chord e
I know I know going all quite a few
chords the major chords now in the minor
chords but when you get into suspended
dog meant these things and all that I
find that I just I don't know what they
are but I'm yeah it was more of the punk
ethic because I goes like this just play
along I'll copy it you're an independent
artist of these days what do you enjoy
most about being I guess not releasing
music on the major labels I enjoy the
lack of money that I make
I really like enjoy the lack of record
sales I okay right away
I enjoy the lack of recognition for
their lack of awards and I like reward
early-season
because quite frankly my mantelpiece was
it was chock-a-block with a sari
it was it's nice to take a back seat
I enjoy not working with people in
record labels who are in fact as we
whole milk it's nice to get away from
that mob I've never felt the need to be
in the public eye or the need even when
it was an Isis I was always the last
person to get on board to go back to the
studio I never really never I don't
chase my I don't taste fame or success
or anything like that I mean I was kind
of like taking about a year out and you
know I'd written a lot I've written a
lot of songs and I demoed most of them
and I just came a point where I just
felt the ice again this usual but not
for any other reason than to record
these songs and see what they sounded
like
and I didn't really tell anybody you
know I kept it quiet for a year and a
half and I'm it was all very relaxed and
low-key there was just me an engineer a
drummer
kind of on a part-time keyboard player
who came in and out so there's like
three of us in there and it was done
very kind of leisurely and then you know
my wife went and got pregnant and saw
that you know I six months off with
looking after my new son another song it
was very less it's quite leisurely pace
some lights a majestic you could have
easily decided to you know start to
retire well yeah yeah they're still what
are enjoying making music well I'd never
lost the sense of wonder of writing
songs you know in that sense I'm still
feel like I'm 25 when I was writing
definitely maybe in thinking us great
you know I just mastered the art of
lying songs I love that every time I
finished the song it was like another
song I still I still get that feeling
and as long as I don't lose that I'll
always make music thank you guys so much
for watching I made this video because I
gpk 1987 asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you are going to
profile next leave it down counts below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know what is an old say that has the
biggest impact on you and why what will
you take from this video and immediately
apply to your life with your business
somehow please leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join in the discussion
I just want to give a quick shout out to
reverse stereo thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book here one
word and making that fun youtube tribute
video I really really really appreciate
your support
[Music]
[Music]
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is let's love you soon